[Music]
welcome back
okay we're talking about the cindy
algorithm which allows us to discover
sparse non-linear models from time
series data
and specifically we've gone through kind
of the overview of the cindy algorithm
and we've identified four key challenges
that i'm talking about in this video
series
so we've already talked about the
challenge of the data how much data
what quality what quantity and so on and
today we're going to
zoom in specifically to this question of
the coordinates
what variables should we measure in the
cindy algorithm
so i want to go back to this picture
here because i think this really
illustrates
the the idea this is the
overview schematic we used to illustrate
cindy for the first time
where you assume that you have data from
a complex system like the lorentz model
and you measure that data in the
variables
x y and z you compute the derivatives
you build the library
and you find the fewest candidate terms
in this library
that are needed to describe x dot y dot
and z dot
so these are terms in the dynamical
system
but there is a huge assumption here that
we usually gloss over
at least when we wrote the first paper
five years ago
we kind of glossed over this big issue
of
how did we know that x y and z were the
right variables to measure
that's a huge amount of upfront
knowledge
about your system that x y and z are the
right systems to measure for the lorentz
system
what if someone gave me this data and it
was rotated a little bit
or distorted a little bit in those
coordinates i might not get a sparse
non-linear representation it might need
a dense representation
with a little bit of all of these terms
in it okay
so that's a key question is how do we
even know what the right variables are
to measure in the first place
now in lots of cases as you know kind of
an
expert scientist or engineer
we know something about our system of
interest
so i highly recommend using cindy as a
tool
for guided model discovery it's not
purely automatic you don't just turn the
crank and get models out
you're the expert you know what your
data is telling you you know what kinds
of models
you think you might want to get out of
this system and you might have an idea
of what variables you're measuring what
the units are
if they're physical if you think that
there would be relationships
so oftentimes you can get a good sense
of if you're in the right coordinate
system or not
kind of as an expert researcher but
there might be cases where we really
don't know
so for example if we're measuring the
brain and we want to get a cindy model
for
patterns in the brain or we're measuring
the spread of a disease on a continent
how do we know if we're measuring the
right variables how do we know if those
are the variables
that admit a sparse representation in
this model space
and so that's the kind of question we're
going to talk about
today okay now
if i have a high dimensional system like
a fluid flow
i already showed you that you can
discover a partial differential equation
that describes this the navier-stokes
equations that's fine
but what if i want an ordinary
differential equation something i can do
uh kind of ode analysis on and i'll
point out
[Music]
this cindy library it expresses a
very large space of possible models
so for example in this set of
polynomials
in x y and z up to fifth order i think
that there are 81 terms in this
this library which means there are 81
coefficients in each of the columns of
c and that means that there are many
possible
model structures that could be encoded
so for example if i wanted a model that
had exactly
two terms two of these column vectors of
theta
i would have 81 choose two
possible models with with two terms
active
if i had three terms in the dynamics i
would have 81
choose three and this gets really big
really fast
so this encodes a tremendous amount of
possible model
structures if we define sparsity
as models that have 10 or less terms
from theta
then there are 81 choose 10
plus 81 choose 9 dot dot possible models
that's more than a quadrillion models
and that's part of the power of this
cindy algorithm
is that it allows you to very
efficiently kind of through sparse
optimization
find out of that huge space of a
quadrillion models
the right structure that actually
describes your dynamics
but there's a catch so the space of
possible models of different structures
is huge
but this library itself actually scales
really poorly
with the dimension of the state vector x
y and z
so we'll talk about that library scaling
issue in the next lecture on the library
but it's something i want you to have in
the back of your mind now because
we can't build a library with
a hundred variables up to fifth order
that would be way too big the library
itself would be too big and so that's an
issue we have when we deal with high
dimensional systems like this
when i simulate this fluid flow on my
computer
i simulate this as a discretized system
of ordinary differential
equations with maybe you know 10 or 100
000 degrees of freedom depending on the
discretization
but we know that there are often low
dimensional coordinate systems where you
can describe this data more efficiently
so even though this requires
10 or 100 000 degrees of freedom to
simulate in my computer
we know that there are these low
dimensional patterns that describe
most of the behavior here and if i write
the dynamics in this coordinate system
in terms of these three modes
the amplitudes of those modes admit a
very simple differential equation
and so that's one way to handle getting
the right coordinates for cindy
is if i have a spatial temporal system
like a fluid flow or a plasma flow or
something like that
i can often take the singular value
decomposition
also known as principal components
analysis or proper orthogonal
decomposition
to get a low dimensional basis in which
i can represent those dynamics
and the amplitudes of these three modes
x y and z
those are the amplitudes that's
generally a very good coordinate system
for representing my dynamics
so if you don't know anything else about
the system but it's high dimensional
the first thing you might want to try is
taking the svd the singular value
decomposition
to get a low dimensional basis where you
can build an efficient library
and start to identify models and when we
do that
for you know the flow past a cylinder
for this example here
we can build our model library in those
three variables it's still
tractable this library is not too big to
work with
and we can identify a model that has the
right structure and the right dynamics
in this coordinate system okay so that's
just a general good idea if you have
high dimensional spatial temporal data
first try taking the svd see if that
gives you a good coordinate system where
you can build models
and we have a lot of theoretical basis
for why we think this might be a good
idea
in fluid mechanics and plasma physics in
lots of spatial temporal systems
because the singular value decomposition
is an orthogonal basis that is kind of
optimally tailored to your particular
data
to represent it as well as possible with
as few degrees of freedom as possible
that's good for our modeling and we also
know that if i take
this expansion this galerkin expansion
and i plug it into
the governing navier-stokes equations
when i expand that out
i get a non-linear ordinary differential
equation in terms of the amplitudes of
these modes
and so it gives us some hope that there
is a differential equation that
describes this evolution
that we can discover using this cindy
algorithm okay
long story short try the spd it really
works in a lot of cases especially
fluids works like a charm
now the svd the singular value
decomposition
can be thought of in kind of modern
neural network language as a
shallow linear autoencoder it
essentially
can be built as a neural network with a
high dimensional input and output
and a single low dimensional latent
layer
given by this z variable where your
network loss function is trying to
minimize the error between
input and output knowing that you're
choking down to only a few degrees of
freedom
and then lifting again so
caveat you never actually want to
compute the svd this way but you can
think of the svd
as this shallow linear auto encoder
which means that if your
svd coordinates aren't quite cutting it
for you if they're not quite good enough
for
building cindy models you could
generalize this into a deep
non-linear autoencoder so instead of
just a single hidden layer
this deep auto encoder has many many
later layers for the encoder
and many layers for the decoder and it
also has nonlinear activation functions
so what this allows you to do is instead
of
building a orthogonal subspace a linear
subspace
the deep autoencoder is designing a
nonlinear manifold that's parametrized
by
z and oftentimes that allows us to
massively reduce the number of degrees
of freedom
required to describe these dynamics
good and so that's exactly the strategy
that kathleen champion took
in designing her cindy auto encoder
framework so so i think this is one of
my favorite papers
that came out of the lab this is work
with kathleen champion
who is a phd student with nathan cuts in
me
bethany lush who is a postdoc with us
nathan and myself and essentially what
kathleen did here
is combine the
power of an auto encoder to learn good
coordinate systems
with a sparse non-linear model in the
latent space
z so this is super cool autoencoders
learn good coordinate systems or
manifolds that describe your data
and you can add additional constraints
in the loss function of this this neural
network training
so that the dynamics on that latent
layer are
sparse nonlinear models in this kind of
cindy framework
so essentially uh there are these
additional loss terms that allow us to
train this model
to find good coordinates and cindy
models
and i'll talk about this again in the
next lecture on
on the library but i want to allude to
it here
which is oftentimes polynomials are not
the right
terms to describe your dynamics maybe
you have sines and cosines or bessel's
functions or
some exotic non-linearity well
oftentimes by applying the right
coordinate transformation
you can transform your system into a
coordinate system where polynomials are
a better
library to model your dynamics this is
very closely related to
normal form theory from classical
dynamical systems
which essentially says that through
subsequent coordinate transformations
you can essentially kill terms in a
taylor expansion
and get sparse polynomial models for
your dynamics
so there's a lot of theoretical
foundations for why this is a good idea
and it's one of my absolute favorite
approaches to cindy when you really
have kind of complex data
and so in this example you could take a
very complex high dimensional system so
this is
uh you know i don't know maybe 100
degrees of freedom in space
and time series measurements of this
evolving and through the autoencoder you
can learn a coordinate transformation
where the dynamics are sparse and in
this case i believe that the discovered
model
was actually a different sparse model
but if you rotated this model you
recovered the original lorentz system
which is super cool so up here all we
had was high dimensional data
and underneath it there were some
lorentzian dynamics
so we could learn the coordinate
transformation that gave us a sparse
model
that was within a rotation of the true
lorenz dynamics
so i think that's pretty cool and we'll
talk more about this this later
okay good um a couple other things you
can do so i've been talking now about if
you have really high dimensional
measurements how do you crunch those
down using either
linear svd coordinates or a non-linear
auto encoder
but what if you have too few
measurements that's also very often the
case maybe i have a complex system and i
have one scalar measurement or two
scalar measurements
you know i have an electrode in the
brain what can i get from that kind of
data
and so this paper really changed the way
i think about
uh about these sparse models this is
work with
jc lazo and baron noak where we were
modeling fluid flow systems like the
flow past this three cylinder
configuration and we didn't want
to assume that we had the full
measurements of the entire velocity
field everywhere
that's a pretty big assumption if i'm
flying you know a boeing aircraft i
don't have the full wake velocity
measurements behind my wing
i might have a few pressure measurements
along the wing or i might be able to
measure my lift and drag
and so what jc showed is that if you
just had lift and drag measurements on
these three cylinders
and you had clean enough measurements
that you could compute the derivatives
you can actually build very accurate
cindy models
in those lift and drag coordinates those
intrinsic coordinates
and this is kind of uh the lift you know
on the three airfoils
from the simulations the direct
numerical simulations that's the ground
truth
and from our cindy models in the blue
dash line almost perfect agreement
so one of the nice things about these
cindy models is that because it's using
regression
it can find sparse models that
approximate the dynamics on kind of
strange variables you wouldn't think to
model on
like lift and drag and there's a lot of
associated benefits with modeling in
these coordinates
that i'll talk about in the video on
sparse fluid modeling
good okay one of the last things i'll
show you
here is if you have
too few measurements again if you if
there's some variables you're not
measuring some latent states
what do you do with that and this came
about because
of a reviewer comment in our original
cindy paper five years ago we got some
fantastic
insightful comments from the referees
and one of them was
this so in our lorentz system we assumed
we had access to x y and z
and we could compute the derivatives but
what if we only had access to x what if
there were hidden variables y and z
just weren't available to us in this
measurement what could we do
with cindy and so this actually started
an entire new research
avenue in our in our collaborative
groups
along kind of latent dynamics and time
delay coordinates and it's a fascinating
story there's a lot more to this i'm
just giving you the high level sketch
so we're assuming that we're measuring a
limited subset of measurements
and we don't have access to the full
state
so you know we just have x measurements
what you can do under certain conditions
given by the tokens delay embedding
for non-linear chaotic systems or by
observability for linear dynamical
systems
you can essentially build a matrix of
time delayed coordinates of this scalar
measurement x
so this is a henkel matrix where each
column
is an augmented vector of your state at
either past or future times so x at time
one time two time 3 dot dot to time q
and you can build this big matrix you
can compute its singular value
decomposition
and you can essentially discover eigen
time delay coordinates
or these little short time trajectories
that allow you to embed this x
measurement
into a higher dimensional space given by
these
called these rows of v this is a classic
delay embedding this is not something we
invented this has been around
since the 80s doing this svd on the
henkel matrix
but when you then try to apply cindy to
this system here some very interesting
things happen
so you can essentially try to design a
cindy model in these v
coordinates and these time delay
coordinates and when we find the
sparsest model and we allow ourselves to
have nonlinear terms and linear terms
we find that the sparsest models tend to
be
linear honest-to-goodness linear models
with no quadratic terms no cubic terms
just linear and this has deep
connections it turns out to coupement
operator theory
we kind of discovered we stumbled on
this connection
that time delay coordinates essentially
provide
almost an optimal coordinate system to
getting a coupeman linear system
a sparse coupeman linear system and
we've written
you know four or five follow-on papers
exploring the structure of this
why it works how it works applying it to
chaotic systems and deterministic
systems and we've learned a lot
so i'll put some links to those papers
and
videos in in the description
and this model allows you to do things
like predict
even very chaotic dynamics um you know
so like you can predict when you're
about to switch lobes to the other side
of the lorenz attractor
and you can even color code your
attractor based on when it's essentially
acting like a linear system and when
it's about to switch
things like that so we learned about
this because we were trying to handle
cindy
on systems with latent variables and so
it turns out that time delay coordinates
plus cindy gives you a very very
accurate
koopman linear model okay there's like a
whole
many papers and an hour-long video on
this so i'm not going to
dwell on this for too long just a long
way of saying
you can handle latent measurements
oftentimes by delay embedding
and this is actually something kathleen
champion explored quite a bit
which is for non-chaotic systems you
often get a perfectly closed model
using those delay embeddings with the
cindy regression procedure
okay good so we've been talking about
this kind of big
cindy overview and specifically these
key challenges
so now we've covered challenge zero of
the data challenge one
of the coordinates and in the next
videos we're going to talk about the
library
so how do you actually build that theta
matrix so it's well conditioned
so that it describes the dynamics of
your system so that it's not too large
and what optimization algorithms do we
use to actually find
those sparse models in the first place
okay all coming up soon
thank you
you